jetzt wird es buch hier roboter in
meinem körper nano roboter sollen das
können forschungsteams arbeiten weltweit
daran und die ersten prototypen sind
tatsächlich vielversprechend
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht übrigens wie ihr zu whatsapp
tom bender gar nicht da sei der fahrer
am ende des videos und jetzt dazu alle
wichtigen facts machen sie uns
vielleicht bald schon unsterblich was
können sie was andere behandlungen nicht
können jetzt in science fiction herzlich
willkommen
es klingt zunächst wie science fiction
aber forschungsteams weltweit sind
tatsächlich dran miniroboter die
selbstständig den körper checken medizin
an die richtige stelle bringen patienten
und patientinnen von innen wieder
zusammenflicken und große op s
durchführen nano box könnten die zellen
unseres immunsystems anregen erreger zu
bekämpfen oder gar selbst krebszellen in
den selbstmord treiben und in den
letzten jahren ist viel passiert in
diesem bereich viele fortschritte wurden
gemacht die anforderungen annahme bots
sind groß zunächst einmal dürfen sie auf
keinen fall in den kapillaren stecken
bleiben also in den ganz engen blutbahn
besten sollen sie sogar so klein sein
dass sie sich zwischen die zellen der
kapillaren in das durchblutetes gewebe
zwecken können und hier liegt das erste
problem denn je kleiner das bauteil
dafür ist die oberfläche wird im
vergleich zum volumen immer größer
bestimmte dinge wie kugellager die wir
aus großen maschinen kennen sind sogar
nicht mehr kontrollierbar
beziehungsweise würden viel zu groß eine
idee zur lösung dieses problems kommen
von shawn das aus san francisco
er hat nano bots entwickelt die etwa so
groß sind wie ein bild auf einer
festplatte also etwa 35 mal 35 nanometer
konkret handelt es sich um hexagonalen
röhren die nachrichten in ihrem inneren
beherbergen und sie bestehen aus dna dem
speichermedium des lebens wenn sie in
kontakt mit dem richtigen zelltyp kommen
geben sie ihre nachricht preis dazu dass
seit ein paar jahren kann man mit
speziellen computerprogramm dna ketten
so aufbauen dass sie sich danach von
ganz allein zu etlichen verschiedenen
formen zusammenfalten
ich habe damit bisher bestimmt über 100
verschiedene strukturen erzeugt
angelehnt sind diese name boards an die
entdeckung einer faltkunst namens dna
origami im jahr 2006 diese technik hat
sich auch ein forschungsteam der arizona
state university zunutze gemacht die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben nano bots auf dna basis entwickelt
die eigenständig krebstumore suchen und
noch viel mehr
in tierversuchen attackierten die nano
bot nicht nur mehr tumore und metastasen
erfolgreich
sondern schnitten ihnen auch noch wird
thematisch die blutzufuhr ab konkret
heftet sich ein adapter des nano boards
an ein tumor blutgefäß dass nanoröhrchen
entfaltet sich und das eingelagerte
thrombin wird frei sorgt für
blutgerinnung und der krebs tumor stirbt
ab zitat wir haben damit das erste
autonome dna basierte roboter system für
eine zielgerichtete krebstherapie
entwickelt diese technik kann gegen ganz
unterschiedliche krebsarten eingesetzt
werden da auch die blutgefäße die die
krebszellen ernähren in allen fällen
gleich aufgebaut sind
das sagt einer der beteiligten forscher
jahren
aber es gibt weitere herausforderungen
wie sollen angebots im menschlichen
körper gesteuert und angetrieben werden
wie kann man sie nach dem eingriff am
besten aus dem körper entfernen ein
forschungsteam aus manchester hat ein
programmierbares molekulares pick up
system entwickelt ein winziger
roboterarm konstruiert auf biologischen
makromolekülen kann gezielt einzelne
moleküle aufnehmen kontrolliert bewegen
und auch wieder absetzen
diese drei schritte nehmen nur wenige
sekunden in anspruch die erfolgsrate
immerhin 80 prozent der name bot besitzt
einen ph sensitiven motor
beziehungsweise rotor wird dass er durch
die gezielte zugabe von säuren und basen
gesteuert werden kann
dieses konzept will das forschungsteam
jetzt auch auf andere verbindungen
übertragen denn bislang ist es nur mit
einer bestimmten moleküls möglich doch
es gibt nicht nur nano boards auf dna
basis ein forschungsteam aus manchester
und hongkong hat jetzt vor kurzem bot
aus spirulina algen gebastelt ein
entscheidender durchbruch die vorteile
dieser bio it bots liegen auf der hand
sie fluoreszieren und außen bestehen sie
aus magnetischen eisenoxid so lassen sie
sich jederzeit im körper orten aufspüren
und aktivieren denn sie sind quasi
magnetisch und können sich so
fernsteuern lassen
das forschungsteam beschreibt wie ihre
bots arzneimittel freisetzen die
krebszellen angreifen dazu einer der
beteiligten forscher costas kostenlos
die entwicklung von nano bot jeden
körper angetrieben und gelenkt werden
können war und ist ein heiliger gral in
diesem
bereich dennoch ist auch klar dass hier
noch einige arbeit notwendig ist um
erste klinische studien durchzuführen
ein weiterer punkt an dem die forschung
noch dürfte ist der preis der name
boards zwar können auch schon derzeit
ein paar milliarden dna name produziert
werden doch für versuche an größeren
tieren oder auch menschen braucht man
wohl 1000 bis millionenfach größere
mengen im großen und ganzen seht ihr
also selbst nano bots haben tatsächlich
ein riesenpotenzial der riesige vorteil
solcher bots es gibt keine
nebenwirkungen sie können absolut exakt
konstruiert werden und arbeit genau da
wo sie sollen schon heute arbeitet die
medizin mit wirkstoffen medikamenten die
so konstruiert sind dass sie nur da
wirken wo sie sollen so ein inhalator
der ist das beste beispiel feiner nebel
bringt den wirkstoff nur dahin wo er
gebraucht wird in die lunge nicht mehr
der ganze körper wird geflutet es gibt
viel weniger nebenwirkungen bei der
lunge ist das relativ einfach aber an
anderen organen oder bei krebs oft nicht
möglich hier können nano bot die lösung
bringen und uns der unsterblichkeit
zumindest ein wenig näher bringen die
vision wäre dass nahezu alle krankheiten
die lokal auftreten und schwer
zugänglich sind gezielt bekämpft werden
könnten krebs chlamydien und vieles mehr
könnte wirklich ausgerottet werden
wahnsinn wenn er als erstes neues zum
thema an bord so zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen
anderen von mir vom neuesten video vorab
garantiert ihr konto direkt in der
redaktion von pixum mitmachen und mir
themen vorschlagen oder mit abstimmungen
mitbestimmen der direkte draht zu mir
einfach draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das abo mit der glocke vergessen ja hier
geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken kunst organe aus dem 3d
drucker kunst vagina erfolgreich
implantiert ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran